hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play outlast
okay when we last left off
we were going down into the female
section
of the insane asylum now what that means
i have no idea
but wait where am i wait i just loaded
the game back up so i actually don't
know where i
left off ah okay here we go okay i got
it okay
so we're going down this ladder luckily
the big guy was not there
which means that we are able to continue
on without being interrupted or so i
think i'm pretty sure that's
not gonna be the case when i get down
here
let's see and i really don't know what
to expect in the female awards but
i'm pretty sure that it's not gonna be
anything good okay
all right there's my familiar dead body
there
and hello are you dead are you just
exercising
was that that crazy nude ab thing
a lot of dead
that's what they did in vanish to me now
don't you start doing
that to me okay so we found another
ladder here i don't know if there was
anything else down there
i saw that
i didn't see it at first but i saw it
afterwards
hi how you doing i'm markiplier
i'm a youtuber
hi who's out here
what's down here what killed them
i heard noises and clawing and shredding
and ripping i heard a lot of that
oh
oh what do i do do i go for the
backwards
what do i do i saw a thingy wait a
minute
there was someone over there
is that stewie
okay you don't have to be scared of me
what i i can tell we're the same
you still know what's real right the
doctor said
you know right dr barry died before he
even started working here
what kind of experiments does a dead
doctor perform on living patients
that's the question i don't know what
are you talking about
you look just as weird as the other ones
but you seem normal so
uh i guess you're the only one here that
i can trust
the patients know dr wernicke is dead
one asks me what kind of experiments
does a
doctor perform on living patients what
is project wall rider
okay buddy it's good to know you are
here and safe you stay safe all right
all right i'm going down here i don't
want to know what was out there so
there is something beast you like and
deadly down here with me
i'm oh is that all blood
is that all blood that's all blood isn't
it that is just a
ah that was a way different ragdoll than
i've ever seen before
that was nice okay all right no time to
waste around yes this indeed
is all blood that is a lot of blood
okay
oh i'm getting horrific
i'm getting horrific flashbacks
to vanish oh look water physics
that's kind of cool
what what do you mean i can't go down
here there's no oh
oh you're joking me i gotta go through
the river of blood into wherever the
hell i'm
going next i just need to keep my camera
up the
entire time my character seems to be
breathing kind of heavy
he's whimpering like a little baby come
on toughen up guy
there's nothing scary down in these
sewers besides whatever the hell is
gonna
kill us all wait was there something
maybe i could see something
hello anybody home no okay
i do believe this place is vacant
i do believe i'm all alone let's see if
there's something else that i can find
here
oh oh man all of that just kind of gave
me the heebie-jeebies i seriously was
like
cause vanish is set in the sewers right
so obviously there were some parallels
drawn
hopefully nothing bad will happen
in this sewer in this horror game where
so far everything bad has happened
hopefully now oh crap
oh and once again i gotta say that the
ambi
all right all right enough of that i
fell in the water
the ambiance of this game is absolutely
stellar compared to a lot of games that
i've played what am i
oh i see okay oh can't see
put that okay all right there is don't
tell me the
what's that oh i said hey look it
between your legs eh
okay so what oh crap my battery okay
so there is something in here i'm hoping
it's not a water monster like an amnesia
probably not right right right
right right
right
okay okay i haven't found a battery in a
while not that i've needed it
luckily i've been able to stockpile you
moved
okay
i heard that that was something moving
around in the water you can't tell me
there wasn't something moving around oh
god if there's a freaking water monster
in here i will lose my
[ __ ] okay
i hear okay never mind i'm gonna i'm
just gonna shut up until something
actually happens
because right now
what fell what's with the goop why is
there goop all over the walls what the
hell fell
what is that what is that i don't know
don't care getting out of here going the
hell away from here
get get out of my way let me out thank
you
okay i think we're good
oh i fell in the water okay
i'm freaking myself out nothing's
actually happened i'm just panicking for
no reason
oh is there anything i actually need
down here
i don't know what is that sound
is that my heartbeat or was that
something else this is a big room
whatever it is
probably probably not a good sign
that i'm having a big room all by myself
okay whatever whatever whatever
i heard that
i hear that that's the thing
that's a second oh that's the thing oh
there's something over there
there's something over there you can't
be there
oh no reload battery oh it's dark
where is that oh that's just the light
i hear it you can't tell me i don't
it's freaking breathing
it's got chains ah it's there it's
the big guy it's a big guy it's a big
guy he's so big
and strong good thing he can't see me
right
oh he's probably following the sound of
my splish splashes oh why do i gotta be
splashing so loud oh don't breathe on me
don't breathe on me i don't want any
oh man that was so i'm actually you know
it's weird i'm kind of relieved
that it's the big guy because at least i
know what it is i swear for like
a good few mi excuse me a good few
minutes there
i had no idea if anything was actually
there that was
so well done i didn't even know if that
was intentional that was just
really well done okay wait was there
something on there that i needed
no just like potted plants or something
i can't see anything
wait a minute ah there's a ladder there
where is he
looking for eyes looking for eyes i
don't see eyes
okay where is he i think he's ah no
okay either way don't oh crap
how do i get up there oh
okay good enough still alive gonna make
it
i'm the best ever there ever was
no no no no no no no no no no
ha ha ha ha ha ha
oh man that was really well done how are
you doing here
you're handling everything okay oh
don't look at me like that don't look at
me like that you're weird
wait he literally looks up when i look
crouched down at him it's so weird okay
anyway enough of that
wait mail ward did i start out in the
female ward
what are you doing hey hey ah oh no oh
no
ah get away from me get back get back
get back for me
i'm just gonna keep running how about
that no how about
no how about new okay
okay i think i'm actually headed towards
oh crap ah crap now he's gonna smack me
in the balls oh i see okay
wait yeah i am going towards the male
ward i thought for this whole time i was
going towards the female ward
oh what was that
who was that i got the bad feeling it's
the friend i made in the last part the
really really weird guy
okay
i'm sorry did i bother a demonic ritual
little piggy little piggy no no go home
little piggy no bother
me i'm picky little piggy you gotta go
on
free okay all right
we're okay everything's good
kind of everything's of good
wow that is a lot of dead
i thought this sewer couldn't smell any
worse hundreds of bodies crammed into a
room
thousands of flies is this the priest's
way out
god i hope not oh good
how many people were working at this
asylum there's so many dead bodies
so many dead bodies
oh it was just the objective thing i
heard that noise again i was like
oh i get it move forward to push
what why am i pushing this oh
okay i got it i see a light there
there's something behind
here i wouldn't have known that if the
thingy didn't come up ah oh
you better not be that guy you're that
guy
don't be that guy you're that guy ain't
you you're that guy
you're the same one don't tell me you're
not
where are you bleeding from okay i
thought the lights were gonna go out
okay we're okay
we're okay right buddy right friend
all right
carrying on whatever the hell's over
here
squeak battery
battery battery no
okay there's nothing in here oh oh oh
close okay this is the door never mind i
was wrong
all right so
guess we go this way it's like a maze i
have no idea where i'm going
why do all well i kind of clip through
the two in there why do i
who's doing that who's doing that
where who's doing that oh
i see hey buddy
how you doing you're not really in a
good
is he actually gonna bust through there
or what
okay what is that the camera can i pick
that up okay
i have a bad feeling
how do i
why am i pushing it i i have no idea i'm
opening this door
for some stupid-ass reason i'm opening
this door
oh i'm sure nothing bad will happen yeah
okay not that way not that way wait what
oh okay all right so i think i'm almost
to the male ward
i hope i really hope okay all right
let's go into this vent
like always oh good
good i'm in some demented hospital
did that say too alive
okay i may be able to climb up there let
me there are people actually behind here
that's not a good thing okay i'm gonna
climb up wait hang on i think i saw a
file there good
file hello wow holy crap
that is messed up man okay let's read
the journal
see this patient also unfortunately
didn't make it i tried my best but i'm
just a doctor not a miracle worker
and i'm pretty new to this whole doctor
thing so i'm still working out all the
kinks
anywho somebody's got to cut the fat
from this project wall rider disaster
we've been bleeding money ever since
this thing went tits up on account of
that billy kid
but i managed to slim back personnel by
more than 80 people
i wonder how which means short-term
savings and salary and long-term savings
and pension and health care costs and
i've been figuring out a lot of biology
i was on the fence about it before but i
now i can say with absolute certainty
that a person cannot live without his
kidneys
you learn something new every day wow
good job there friendo okay
man this whole deal is just getting
messed up man
everything about this is just so strange
and it's what's weird is that that note
was written so nonchalantly just like
ah everything went tense up when wall
riders started devouring people and
tearing their intestines out
good thing i landed in this soft puddle
of goop
oh
are those the twins the naked twins
oh you're going to kill me you're going
to kill me oh god damn it god
dang it dang it dang it dingus ah
where'd you come from
i died i died i died horribly
i died horrifically oh well
it happens what was i supposed to do i
got in this room with the guy and i bust
i i guess i wasn't fast enough
oh i know what i need to do i need to
close the damn doors behind me
come on come on come on come on come on
there we go okay
there we go there we go there we go
there we go there we go close it close
and close and close it
lock it lock and lock it push it come on
would you
there's no other way eat that guy in
there jeez
stop being such a douche you have a meal
ready for you
if i was pushing this i would push those
way faster
oh okay there we go oh that's not good
wait where's my where's my thing on
camera there we go boom
oh close that lock it up
all right dr wernicke is not gonna help
you now
okay okay up here all right
all right i think we're gonna survive
this
isn't that just great ah no come on how
is that even fair
how's that even fair okay oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh okay no i'm going the
right way all right
and epicly yeah
what now buddies a-holes
suck on that all right we did it we did
it guys and we are just out of time so
that will do it for this part
oh stop being such a baby it's only
imminent death that you just escaped so
thank you all so much
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that i'm
done
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
at wow